well some of the claims made in the book
have prompted some renewed questions
about security after Prince Harry shared
details of his military record while
serving in Afghanistan saying that he
killed 25 Taliban fighters well a little
bit earlier we spoke to Lord Kim darog
the former National Security adviser and
here's what he told us personally if
I've been advising the prince I would
have advised against the kind of detail
that he goes into I believe it was a
just war and therefore what he has
written about how he justified himself
what he was doing I can understand and
appreciate that but in terms of the
detail I personally wouldn't have gone
there but it's done now
well in a moment I'll be speaking to our
Royal correspondent Laura bundock who's
at Buckingham Palace for us this morning
but first with more on the revelations
contained in the book Sky's Katie
Spencer is here with me and Katie it
really is extraordinary isn't it in
terms of the the how candid he is and
how many Revelations there actually are
not least over his time in Afghanistan
yeah it is very interesting how much
detail he's felt the need to to give in
terms of particularly things like his uh
time that he spent in Afghanistan given
his concerns that he's spoken about in
the past about the security for his
family and how he feels that since
leaving the UK he hasn't had the same
security detail and the same protection
um to to go on and to detail how many
Taliban fighters he knows that he's
killed certainly one would think that
that does up the risk that he has now
given for his family in terms of
revealing details like that if you look
in certain countries in the Twitter
reaction into that Revelation in
particular it certainly has provoked a
strong reaction in some countries
there's a lot of Revelations in this
book it's a it's a big book this is a
Spanish copy that we've got hold of the
translations that we've been working
through to to get this back into English
there are so many news lines that he
gives here yes he talks about how he
found out about the death of his mother
he comes across as a terribly sad a
terribly damaged individual in this he
talks about the PTSD that he experiences
panic attacks his time that he's had to
spend in therapy since then
um it's a lot of sharing clearly he
wants to be someone that Advocates
talking about your mental health for
very good reasons but you do end up
wondering just how how the effect of of
sharing so much will be on him he says
that he dislikes the the tabloids with a
real anger towards how they've treated
him and his family in the past but he is
with this book feeding them so many
lines of details about his life many of
details of which were perhaps
unnecessary that we didn't need to know
he talks there's moments he comes across
as being quite Petty quite petulant he
talks about his brother's hair loss
being worse than his own he's makes
references to things like the the Nazi
uniform that he ended up wearing as a to
a fancy dress party and whilst trying to
apologize he also wants to slip in
details about how well his brother
William and Kate were also aware of what
him the fact that he was going to be
wearing that uniform
um so at times it sounds very bitter at
times it sounds very Petty but the main
overriding sense you get from this book
is just how sad and damaged he is by by
the things that he's gone through indeed
well Casey thanks very much indeed